okay five guys
elon he's weird right that would kind of
create elon musk would be i like his
face but um can we get a couple r b
singers i feel like they yeah why not
stevie wonder
stevie wonder is a good one yeah because
he wouldn't know what the [ __ ] was good
you know i mean that's my dick oh i
thought that was betty white's [ __ ]
immediately i thought it was a fantastic
did you guys hear that like stevie
wonder is a womanizer and i always
wonder how he knows who's good looking
when they come into the room ed sheeran
or louis capaldi
lewis capaldi uh
oh you know who i want in there that's
not obese derek lewis yes oh my how did
you know gilbert because you mentioned
jamar neighbors a while ago and i don't
think yeah you're okay
right now yeah so i would you know what
but also eric lewis 100 it's the black
bees come on guys also we don't have any
black people in it yet all right and we
need a fifth guy now hey wait these
people can't get out of it right they
can't opt out no no no they can't opt
out okay then i would throw joe rogan in
there